sandrine potel tout grain de peau d'âne
ce jour là c'est peau d'âne qui
recueille le plus de suffrages mais à
bretagne les comptes il y en a huit 8
scènes qui retrace ses histoires de
charles perrault
le dernier né du chaton c'est barbe
bleue et son cabinet interdite qui cache
de lourds secrets
pour cette nouvelle mise en scène les
équipes on misait sur les lumières et la
vidéo au coeur de l'ancien salon de
chasse du château il faut allier la
tradition et la modernité donc à voir
les personnages de cire du musée grévin
respecter le lieu dans lequel la scène
est présenté et puis apporter une vision
artistique et les nouvelles technologies
notamment les effets vidéo lumière le
son tout cela permet de bien de créer
une atmosphère qui j'espère unique une
rénovation vingt ans après sa création
l'une des toutes premières histoires à
être comptés sent bon la galette et le
petit pot de beurre
nous sommes ici dans l'ancienne maison
de jeux des enfants de la famille de
breteuil qui a été construite
spécialement pour eux à la fin du 19e
siècle et cette maison a été réaménagé
dans les années 80 au xxème siècle pour
y installer la scène de conte du petit
chaperon rouge c'est un peu la scène
expérimentale c'est à dire que c'est la
plaine des premières qui a été installé
ici avec des personnages de cire et puis
en 2012 c'est la première que nous avons
adapté en son et lumière
et bien voici le futur chantier la
prochaine restauration ce sera la
dernière scène de compte en son et
lumière un chantier qui nous attendra
pour 2020 ce petit poucet n'a pas évolué
depuis sa création les équipes
réfléchissent à comment le faire voyager
et vous faire chausser vous aussi les
bottes de sept lieues
[Musique]